est ce la fin est ce la mort de netflix
est ce que c'est la dégringolade qu'est
ce qui se passe réellement je sais pas
si vous êtes abonnés netflix moi je fais
un bolide et de félix je suis pas affolé
que netflix mais je suis entre autres
abonnés netflix et on constate que ça va
pas il ya un vrai dévissage en bourse et
de grosses pertes d'abonnés et on peut
se demander si tout ça ne va pas se
répercuter sur vous vous qui êtes encore
abonnés ce qu'il va encore y avoir une
hausse de prix est ce que ça va coûter
encore plus cher est-ce que netflix va
pouvoir continuer à subsister avec cette
grosse concurrence bref est-ce que
netflix pas continuer à vivre oui
soyons clairs il ya une très grosse
perte d'abonnés chez netflix - deux cent
mille abonnés qui ont été perdus il n'ya
pas longtemps et la dégringolade devrait
continuer à se faire dans les temps à
venir donc c'est pas juste un truc du
moment ça va continuer ils ont continué
à perdre et ça ne va pas du tout et si
vous regardez les chiffres de la bourse
vous voyez une dégringolade à ça c'est
pour la journée aujourd'hui je tourne
les le 25 avril donc ça pour la journée
d'aujourd'hui on voit que ça commence à
dégringoler mais si vous remontez à un
an et ça nous intéresse vous voyez la
chute vertigineuse on a une progression
2021 c'est monté jusqu'à la fin d'année
seo et ensuite ça se casse la gueule
mais vraiment fortement et là regardez
même aujourd'hui la dégringolade elle
fait extrêmement mal une très grosse
perte de la valeur boursière de netflix
et on sait pas jusqu'où ça va aller
qu'est ce qui va se passer par la suite
je sais pas si vous avez les abonnements
des deux flics mais ça coûte cher ça
coûte très cher netflix vient augmenter
ses tarifs pour quelles raisons pour
venir augmenter les productions
augmenter le nombre de production
augmenter la qualité des productions
c'est une vraie guerre aujourd'hui qu'on
va retrouver au niveau de toutes ces
plateformes de streaming c'est d'avoir
le meilleur catalogue alors disney plus
c'est facile sont disney sont des marvel
bref ils ont très gros catalogues et qui
est hyper sexy prime sur les droits du
foot déjà depuis peu donc si vous êtes
foutus vous avez peut-être un abonnement
chez prime vidéo et en plus de ça je
crois qu'ils ont racheté catalogue
warner c'est warner si je me trompe pas
c'est à dire qu'ils ont notamment tous
les james bond que vous trouverez pas du
coup chez netflix donc c'est vraiment
ils vous regehr de catalogues et netflix
a fait le choix d'augmenter ses tarifs
on y est proposé des productions
toujours plus léché toujours plus de
qualité toujours plus de quantité
également alors des flics c'est quoi
c'est un catalogue avec notamment ce
quiz games qui a cartonné on a eu la
carte el papel d'ailleurs plutôt le
début que la fin the clown perdus dans
l'espace il ya de très très gros titres
mais il ya aussi certaines séries qui
sont quand même un peu en dessous parce
qu'il en faut pour tout le monde et il
en faut beaucoup pour avoir un gros
catalogue assez exhaustif pour autant
est-ce que ça suffit à ce que les gens
restent sur les flics c'est la preuve
que non puisque une vraie grosse perte
d'abonnés alors là je me suis posé la
question pourquoi est ce qu on allait
sur les flics dès le départ il faut
revenir un peu au début à l'origine déjà
pour tous à des flics c'est quoi c'est
des productions sont de belles
productions sont belles séries sont à
citer quelques-unes à quelques instants
ils sont arrivés surtout au moment où il
y avait une très faible concurrence et
toutes ces plates formes de streaming
n'existait pas ou comment c'est arrivé
et ils sont arrivés leader sur le marché
parce que quoi parce qu'ils avaient une
très grosse demande c'est super
intéressant c'est pénible avant de
devoir aller louer un dvd une machine
revenir leur avenir sous 24 heures bref
extrêmement pénible là vous avez tout
dans votre ordinateur est d'ailleurs
quand je parle de l'île d'aller louer un
dvd j'ai l'impression d'être dans la
préhistoire qui me semble tellement loin
et puis ils ont eu un truc pour eux
netflix c'est le co vide et ça ça les a
vachement aider les gens sont restés
chez eux pendant plus de deux ans pas
tout à fait pendant plus de deux ans ne
sont quand même resté longtemps chez eux
et quand on est chez soi et qu'on a rien
à faire qu'est ce qu'on fait et bien on
se divertit oh regarde des films des
séries donc une vraie explosion du
nombre d'abonnés aujourd'hui le coup
vite bessan et j'espère que ça va
continuer on croise les doigts et bien
forcément le nombre d'abonnés va
mécaniquement disparaît partir en tout
cas baisser et tout ça ça crée quoi ça
crée un cercle vicieux et ce cercle
vicieux il est assez intéressant à
analyser pourquoi parce que dès lors
vous avez une perte du nombre d'abonnés
à cause de la concurrence parce qu'une
très grosse concurrence à concurrence
c'est quoi aujourd'hui et la concurrence
et ça y ait concurrence au niveau des
tarifs la concurrence et prague vidéo
pré vidéo regardez c'est ça c'est
d'ailleurs parce que j'ai reposé les
chiffres cette vidéo j'ai trouvé ça
complètement fou presse vidéo c'est 49
euros par an alors après vous pouvez
venir louer des films en plus et les
payer un peu plus cher bon ok il ya 10 à
différentes offres là dedans mais de
basse et 49 euros par an pour avoir
catalogue très complet disney plus c'est
plus cher quasiment 90 euros on est
presque au double je dis bien presque 89
euros 90 c'est quand même cher mais vous
avez les marvel d'aeria disney bref ça
emmène du monde neflix vous avez trois
offres principales qui sont liées à la
qualité sd c'est à dire en 480p vous
aérer dans une qualité qui va être
vraiment pas bonne alors sur un mobile
d'accord ne vous êtes à 8,99 par mois
107 euros par an 107 euros pour regarder
en sd sur votre mobile non mais sérieux
ça c'est pas bon moi j'ai un abonnement
full hd 13 49 par mois 161 euros 88 par
en full hd 4k 17 euros 99 215 euros 88
parents est ce que là il n'ya pas quand
même une énorme différence par rapport à
un prime qui a aussi un très beau
catalogue ou indice n'est plus même s'il
est plus cher et encore je vous parle
que de ses catalogues là vous en avez
d'autres alors ce soit en france mais
aux états unis c'est encore pire visage
bio et apparemment bref on a énormément
et ça va continuer à se développer en
france donc c'est sûr que ça permet de
perdre mécaniquement désabonner la fin
du coc vide des tarifs très élevés et
des offres très compétitives est super
intéressante ailleurs baisse d'abonnés
par de confiance des actionnaires au
niveau de la bourse on voit une chute
vertigineuse de là ce qu'est ce qui se
passe quand on perd de l'argent et bien
par des millions si ce n'est des
milliards perdre d'argent perte de
dollars donc perdre de la capacité de
financement des productions et une
diminution des productions soit en
quantité soit en qualité d'ailleurs
c'est ce que j'ai vu aujourd'hui en
janvier recherche un article de elle le
dit très bien neflix le géant du
streaming annuler plusieurs séries suite
à la chute des abonnements et forcément
quand les gens partent une perte de
confiance une perte d'argent une baisse
de production les abonnés par une perte
de confiance une perte d'argent c'est le
cercle vicieux sans fin sauf si netflix
arrive à faire des choses en face alors
regardez vite fait c'est intéressant
qu'est ce qu'ils sont venus annulé il le
marque dont elle ce soit pour moment des
séries d'animation qui sont les
premières victimes de cette nouvelle
politique la série ensorcelante oil et
trois banques et l'adaptation de la
bande dessinée bonne et de tweets une
série adaptée du livre pour enfants bref
il commence un petit peu il y aller tout
doucement je pense qu'ils se disent on
va pas tout coupé on va pas tous côtés
on va garder ce qui fonctionne mais
malgré tous les signaux sont la baisse
la production ils enlèvent des
productions donc ils vont continuer à
perdre des abonnés perte de confiance
bref c'est le cercle vicieux une fois de
plus alors est-ce que neflix pour venir
compenser une perte d'abonnés va venir
augmenter ses tarifs je vois pas parce
que si vous continuez à augmenter les
tarifs il est évident que vu le tarif
qui est déjà exorbitants les tailles
sont déjà exorbitants les gens
continueront à partir soit 10 n'est plus
soi prime soit les autres il y en a
énormément alors pour réagir netflix a
réfléchi à plusieurs solutions qui ne
serait pas forcément à votre avantage
pas forcément donne le premier point
c'est le partage je sais pas vous faites
plus si vous avez un compte netflix un
conte canal ou quoi que ce soit souvent
on peut partager son mot de passe avec
plusieurs personnes mais on le fait
c'est à dire que moi par exemple j'ai
justin ma compagne qui regardent
également parce que c'est un partage
familial mon fils à son compte également
mais peut-être l'avez-vous partagez-vous
avec des amis avec votre famille qui est
un peu plus éloignés géographiquement
avec un ami qui est loin ou à l'autre
bout du monde j'en sais rien ou quoi ça
c'est possible ça ça représenterait 100
millions de personnes qui utilisent
netflix au travers du partage de mots de
passe sont ne payez absolument rien donc
ce que pourrait proposer ici netflix ça
serait de limiter forcément se partagent
des mots de passe surtout de le faire
payer il pourrait proposer ok vous
voulez partager le mot de passe avec
quelqu'un de votre famille et bien vous
allez payer peut-être en europe
peut-être deux euros de plus par contre
qui aura accès à votre mot de passe ça
pourra faire râler alors après on
pourrait se dire qu il on ferme aussi
une géolocalisation en disant vous en
considère que vous habite à cette
adresse et que l'autre personne avec qui
vous ai fait un partage familia qui doit
donc être dans votre foyer si elle n'est
pas géolocaliser régulièrement chez vous
et bien auquel cas on considéra voulais
partager quelqu'un d'autre qui devrait
payer un abonnement donc on va couper ce
partage c'est aussi une possibilité donc
ce qui pourrait bénéfique pour netflix
et récupéré parmi les 100 millions de
personnes par exemple se récupère ne
serait-ce qu'un tiers et bien 33
millions de personnes qui pourrait venir
s'abonner et ça permettrait d'augmenter
les rentrées d'argent de rassurer de
venir casser en gros ce cercle vicieux
on augmenterait non d'abonnés ont
récupéré la confiance ont récupéré de
l'argent et on pourrait investir dans
les productions ça pourrait être le
cercle vertueux autre choix sur lequel
netflix est en train de bosser c'est une
formule un peu moins cher pour venir se
mettre face à la concurrence mais
surtout avec de la publicité à
l'intérieur que vous payerez y est vous
pour votre abonnement mais vous auriez
en plus de la publicité qui viendrait se
mettre au début d'un film au début d'une
série quand on sait qu'on enchaîne les
séries de 33 minutes 40 minutes une
heure on les enchaîne on aurait de la
pub à chaque fois donc on paierait un
peu moins cher mais on aurait de la pub
ça permettrait de financer peut-être
d'équilibré voire d'augmenter un petit
peu les recettes de netflix d'ailleurs
je sais pas si vous vous seriez d'accord
avec ça ce que vous seriez d'accord vous
en disant je paye un abonnement et en
plus c'est de la pub pour moi semble
aller à l'encontre du système même moi
j'ai un abonnement spotify si j'ai pris
un abonnement spotify c'est justement
pour ne plus avoir ces pubs donc là on
retrouve avec des pubs et payer un peu
moins cher non pour moi ça marcherait
pas et puis la finalité des finalités
des finalités ce qui coûte cher à des
flics sont les productions ils ont bien
dit on augmente les prix pour augmenter
les productions augmenter les cats et
augmenter la qualité et augmenter le
catalogue donc s'ils veulent gagner en
coupe pour venir équilibrer tout ça et
rassurer les actionnaires il va falloir
baisser les charges les coûts liés à la
production donc diminuer probablement
les productions diminuer le catalogue
était au final venir probablement moins
vous séduire et risquer de perdre des
abonnés ok maintenant il faut
relativiser tout ça il est évident que
si netflix perd des abonnés à cause du
coc vide ça va être pareil pour les
autres qui mécaniquement vont perdre des
abonnés à cause du coville mais
imaginons quand on est chez soi sur une
période de covile peut-être parce que
c'est votre cas avez vous souscrit à
plusieurs abonnements dites le moi en
commentaire moi j'ai un abonnement prime
jeunes abonnement 10 les plus j'ai la
bonne idée fixe j'ai tous les trois je
les regarde de temps en temps mais pas
tout le temps et je regarde beaucoup de
vidéos youtube donc je suis pas tout le
temps en train de regarder les choses
pour lesquelles je paye mais on se dit
qu'à un moment il va falloir faire des
choix est-ce que c'est intéressant de et
regardez là je suis à 90 euros et à 140
euros et là je suis à 300 euros ne
serait ce que pour avoir ces plateformes
là est-ce que c'est pas le moment
justement devenir réduire ses coûts là
le coc vide se levant pour moi c'est
clair donc je pense que netflix paie le
prix de son prix trop élevés au
détriment des autres qui sont beaucoup
moins chères avec de beaux catalogues
derrière alors à la question est ce la
mort de netflix je ne pense pas je ne
pense pas parce que la publicité qui
pourrait arriver qu'un forcer un peu
moins cher ça serait dans un an deux ans
pas avant il faut du temps pour venir
faire une étude de marché et venir
restructurer tout ça alors il est
évident que ça ne va pas changer ça ne
va pas bouger je pense cette année mais
dans tous les cas et ce qui est
intéressant ici c'est que dans la mesure
où netflix souffre ça va être à votre
bénéfice à vos au bénéfice du
consommateur donc pour moi ça va dans
votre sens ça vous va dans notre sens à
nous ça dans mon sens à moi ça dans
votre sens à vous puisque ils vont être
obligés de s'aligner l'autre obligé de
trouver des solutions pour être moins
chers pour garder un groupe de qualité
parce que s'ils dégradent la qualité du
catalogue ils vont perdre encore plus
d'abonnements et s'il fait encore plus
d'abonnements ils vont pas de la
confiance ils vont perdre de l'argent il
y aura plus d'autorisation boursière ils
vont baisser les pros bref ça ne marche
pas ils sont obligés de garder un
catalogue de qualité donc ils vont faire
quoi pour gagner de nouveaux abonnés ils
vont être obligés d'essayer de jouer au
niveau des tarifs faire un mix trouver
des solutions qui je pense vont dans
notre sens on verra ça en tout cas c'est
pas la fin de l'été flics sont en tout
cas ce que ça montre que c'est super
intéressant c'est que ce marché évolue
un marché qu'on pensait peut-être
arriver certainement à maturité avec
plein de offre d abonnement payant ça
pouvait être intéressant et on voit que
nos en fait c'est pas du tout finie
c'est pas du tout figé il ya des choses
qui vont évoluer et aujourd'hui on se
parle de plates formes de streaming
vidéo mais ça peut aussi bien s'étendre
à toute forme de plateformes de
streaming par abonnement ce soit de la
musique ou même pourquoi pas du jeu
vidéo donc tu expliques ce n'est pas
mort soyez rassurés mais il va se passer
des choses on en reparlera vous en rade
prenez soin de vous et à très vite
charme
[Musique]